attendez si op oui bonsoir madame la
ministre oui bonsoir ça va mais vous
mais ça va car c'est chez france inter
bravo bourdais bien mais je suis en
direct
je vous appelle en direct de l'émission
comment comment vous allez c'est une
journée c'est une journée très
importante pour vous marlène et pour
tout le monde
est ce que est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire un mot non mais ça c'est hyper
important c'est vrai sur le grenelle qui
se passe en ce moment parce que voilà il
ya plein de jeunes qui nous regardent
vous savez dans touche pas à mon poste
et voilà on a envie même de faire passer
ce message que c'est très très important
que vous avez un message à faire passer
marine merci les gars et touche toutes
les tranches d'âge elle touche aussi des
plus jeunes et moi ce que j'aurais à
dire au jeune femme qui regarde c'est
que faut absolument ne pas rester seul
peut pas se laisser isoler numéro 6 et
le 39 19 gratuit et anonyme à et
derrière il ya des actes en les écoutant
de former accompagner les jeunes femmes
leur entourage pour les soutenir et
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse être mise
à l'abri quand elles seront tranquilles
étape qui les unit les menaces voilà
c'est très important je vous dis de
faire passer le message
aujourd'hui ce grenelle il est très très
attendu j'ai vu que c'était vraiment top
tweets aujourd'hui dont on ne parlait
que de ça et je vous le dis n'ayez peur
n'ayez pas peur on pense adresse à
toutes les personnes voilà qui sont
victimes de violences conjugales
n'ayez pas peur d'appeler vraiment
parler c'est le plus important et je
pense j'espère qu'il va avoir beaucoup
de choses qui vont avancer
grâce à ce grenelle bah merci d'avoir
répondu marine va pas